A hundred years ago, that would have been the magic of levitation.
Is it possible to create illusions in a world...
...where technology makes anything possible?
Stay!
If you know how the trick is done, where is the illusion?
Here, boy!
He can do a trick.
Watch.
Up!
Hey, where are you going?
I think there's more to this than meets the eye.
Come back!
Very funny!
Behave yourselves!
As a magician, I have always known...
...that the illusion is in the mind of the beholder.
Once upon a time, this would have been magic.
Today, it is a trick of technology.
But still, our imagination is more powerful than our reasoning.
And it's easy to attribute personality to machines.